哇 今天台灣股市逆轉勝啦
我今天要獨家告訴你
明天就是台積鏈法說了
怎麼看
這最重要的重點
除此以外
SK海力是ADR溢價50%
雖然現在有收斂了
那這個溢價那麼多
涨那麼多
是不是記憶體泡沫
什麼叫溢價
我已經一次跟你講得清楚
第二個
為什麼
現在最強是信息源
為什麼以前是環球經濟不停
今天是中美經濟停
環球經濟下跌
為何呢
還有台積鏈法說會
这三个独家的消息
你今天你不看你会后悔
我好多秘密要跟你讲
台积电法说会要来了
投资长到底该怎么解读呢
昨天台股大跌1700多点
投资朋友们都垂头丧气
但今天台股狂喷大涨千点
收涨在893点
涨停涨停再涨停
投资长的股票更是疯狂
精彩今天开盘不到一分钟的时间
就锁上涨停
再创历史新高
投资涨的我爱美元中美金
这档股票更是夸张
盘中突然发疯
90度急拉喷上涨停
创下快20年新高
还有环球金也在创历史新高啦
投资涨的股票真的太强了
投资朋友们一定很疑惑
今天中美金飙涨停
為什麼環球金反而開高走低
今天到底為什麼會暴漲千點
明天的台積電法說會
又會如何影響台股呢
接下來就交給我們
經濟日報選股冠軍
單季188%的紀錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
郭哲榮投資長
投資長好
莉莉 各位同朋友大家好
哎呀 我跟你說真的
我今天不知道要講什麼
你知道嗎
你看一下我的股票
5347 世界先進
這種拉法啦
這種美金啊
等一下請視角準備一下
看有沒有兩張圖
應該有準備
連續兩天直接90度拉啦
我的股票是有價有量
動輒2、300億成交量
選這種股票
才能證明我的實力
才能知道
我含水會結動
環球金一直漲
現在換中美金
環球金為什麼這樣拉
為什麼今天殺下去
故意的
這是好事
大家跟你講
投資廟
還有台積電法說
我再一次全部講完
我問你一件事
你找到哪個分析師
告訴我有比我強
這些股票
金才直接跳空所值展平
我哪一個不是
都是事先講好幾天
好幾週
至少有時候講到一個月以上
是
精彩講很久
之前沒講的時候
一堆人念我
I don't care
因為那些會念我
都不是我粉絲
都假粉絲
真正我的會員朋友
每個贊不絕口
我告訴你
第一次看我的節目
你說郭忠祐在胡扯
怎麼可能展天都他的
我跟你講
我最不屑
因為就是天天暫停的分音師
因為很多都表演的
可是我告訴你
這次就天天暫停了怎麼辦
這次就天天暫停怎麼辦
我好運啦
不必要怎麼辦
我告訴你
我單分音師20年
你不要看我皮膚很好
很年輕
不好意思
我單分音師20年了
我在股市30年了
我單分音師20年來
每天很認真
每天工作十幾個小時
我睡覺的時候
莉莉你可以作證啦
我們有個群組對不對
是
凌晨2點也會傳訊息
凌晨3點也會傳訊息
沒錯
想到美股有什麼變化
我都傳對不對
對
我到現在還是這樣子
我同事分析
同事分析是20年
投資股是30年
20年以來
最強大的績效是今年
最棒的績效是現在
我跟你講
網友們講這些股票
什麼中美金環球金額
賺100%這些股票
我問你們底下留言
我有沒有講在前面
底下留言
我跟你講
我問大家
我以為有沒有在講在前面
你們有沒有賺到錢
尤其會員朋友們
你告訴我們賺多少錢
唉呀
你覺得我要講啊
而且我選國有價有量
很多人說
你每天講一樣的
廢話
我每天股票都暫停
我當然講一樣的
來 有人講
每天開玩笑啦
1999方案
7月3號加入會員
太晚加入了好不好
關一個中美金
今天會費就賺回來
不好意思
你今天賺回來賺更多
還有5個多月的會員時間
期待能賺更多
有沒有看到
有沒有
這個
謝謝會員的親身證明
這我回答
證明這一屆奇蹟
但中美金不是我賺最多的股票
連前十名都排不到
你看我講話多拽
會員講的
7月3號就加入會員
是
我在台風前
我是不是可以跟你說
不要亂犯台風價
你看你們少買好多
台風前我一直買中美金
我本來買190
我不是說有些會員
在留言的時候抱怨一點點嗎
我說沒關係
你們的抱怨
是我的動力
所以你有沒有看到
現在越來越上很少節目有沒有看到
是
有沒有發現我績效越來越好
因為我最集中精神在你們身上
我越來越集中精神在你們身上
還有公司的管理上面
輔助其他分禮師
反正績效越來越好
你們看啦
7月8日有沒有看到
買啊 7月3日的會員一定買到7月8日
7月9日加上再買一次
只要新會員這幾天加入的都一定買得到
價格都讓你買得到
207 213我還追高有沒有看到
有沒有看到
你看現在231的有沒有看到
不對啦
現在變成254了
不對啦 278了
本來想買190啦
買不到追200元啦
現在變快300元啦
來
粉絲來做作證
我們講前面
有喔 都是會員講的喔
粉絲講的喔
考慮有買AI來算即時字幕嗎
可以算嗎
沒辦法吧
YouTube沒辦法算即時字幕
感謝投資產
買中美金賺10%
你買10%真的有點丟臉
雖然你謝謝我
人生沒有這樣經歷
雖然我不是會員
但是我非常的感恩
我也謝謝你
我說對外丟臉
我不是丟你啦
他們已經真的
賺10%不需要找我
買台灣50也可以
我想真的好不好
500沒有買進凡宣
就再也買不到
我有沒有說精彩噴出去
凡宣會噴
有
你有沒有不理我啊
我說凡宣的員工很認真啊
我有一些會員
剛剛都是凡宣的高層
不要講誰啊
希望他有看到我這一段
那個金金
你可以把這段傳給他
我說人家
每次都很任職在工作
每天都感覺他在世界各國忙
我說這樣 這麼多好員工
這家公司的體質不會太差
500沒有買進房間就再也買不到
這只有一百多萬的粉絲
你覺得裡面不會很多
好不好
你們真的很現實
股票展 點餘率就很低
昨天突然點餘率恐嚇一下
我們有時候點餘率
有時候標題是恐嚇你
不代表我內心的想法
就是台股崩定了
你們都可以直播人數多一點嗎
你們不要每次崩盤的時候才8千1萬好不好
加油啦 不過怎麼樣啦
我們還是全台灣最多訂閱的人啦
沒錯
我們節目動輒還是一二十萬人看啦
是
如果你在股世界你不認識哲哲
你一定是股市菜鳥好不好 OK嗎
法度國隊踢輸了
你賭那些幹嘛
哎呀 我要下一個足球
你知道什麼 我世界盃足球賽我不去賭嗎
看看
為什麼
我很討厭賭博
是
嗯 那哲哲你怎麼會做投資
因為我是投資 我不是投資
我超討厭輸的
我很討厭輸
我就算連完運財 我就是要贏
那我去想想看
那人家研究運財
可能你知道
你們一堆人不知道什麼叫月位
你跟人家賭什麼
你聽懂嗎
是
你知道什麼叫月位嗎
不知道
對啊
有些人不知道去賭
你們賭這些錢幹嘛
我知道你們是覺得小組疑性
我就是愛賺錢的
欸
運彩
賭這些運彩
賭這些市族
有些人研究不足就來賭
何苦呢
我在股票市場
我有時候每天十幾個小時
我都不一定講百分之百
那為什麼我不花最大績效
最大的努力在我的股票上面呢
你聽懂嗎
運彩讓你賺幾千萬嗎
不行啊
我們連發科再國具再裝美金
如果我們一檔再換一檔再換一檔
時間就差不多吧
連發科先發動嘛
對
先展一倍沒錯吧
沒錯
需要我畫給你看線圖嗎
不用吧
連發科展一倍完以後換國具
再展一倍
再換國具完以後再換一倍對不對
再換環球金
你沒錯吧
沒錯
不只喔
這算是一倍一倍一倍喔
100萬變200萬一倍以後
200萬變400萬
400萬變800萬
而且我很多不是一倍啊
是快兩倍啊
對
所以我1000萬可以變8000萬
100萬可以不要不要買海灣
我沒跟你花開玩笑
你看一堆人說
哲哲我有買 問到
有沒有問到
環球金為什麼跌
對不對 剛剛有人講的
剛剛為什麼跌跟人講
什麼
台勝科我跟你講
股票減金會員沒有
我也都很老實跟你講啦
我是老實然到人家的
不然我每天跟你講台勝科
那是老頭顧的手法啦
講一些你他根本摸不到股票
我不用啊
我關是中美金環球金
為你為寶寶
是不是
是
OK嗎
納科 台聖科都好強
都是台座集團
對啊
是不是
兒子300多人就說樊軒可以買
兒子應該是我粉絲嘛 對不對
只是什麼時候會辦演講
我現在辦演講應該五六千人
我跟你講
我就跟你講我現在老了啦
以前說老實話
以前一年那我辦100產演講
我也是全台灣辦最多演講的人
我從一產演講
本來只有三四十個
我第一次辦演講就三四個人
那時候他們的公司高層還嚇到
那時候我菜鳥的時候
我說你怎麼那麼魅力
我到一場到三四千人
我都辦過
我都辦到三百人
覺得哇好厲害喔
台大那個好像什麼
集思會的東西
那時候辦到一百多人
然後再辦到三百多人之後
哇我好厲害
我還沒想到三千人
可是說老實話
現在很累了
老了
看我至少一次
我還沒辦法跨出那個門檻
所以有要辦演講來跟你講好不好
因為我現在辦演講
是一個東西啊
想要見你們
可是對賺錢來講
我覺得沒差
辦演講我會收比較多錢
但我沒有想要
好不好
我沒有想要辦人賺錢
來
來看一下去大劇淡辦
我是分記師
小劇淡都很難塞滿的
可是3000人應該沒問題
好不好
那個台北
台北國際會議中心應該沒問題
好不好
折看起來年輕
謝謝
賺錢就要爽爽花
趕快花
折的素顏比較帥
等一下你們是有看過我嗎
好來
好還是辦演唱會
不要開玩笑
所以你看一堆會員都有講的
有沒有看到
收看錄帶千萬
他關收看還是會員不知道
謝謝哲的專門金讓我一張賺10萬有沒有看到
空前絕後我是潛意師
我是講的啦
你可以去問所有會員
有參加我好幾年的
今年是我這分心是20年來
最強的績效啦
我就跟你講的
我股票是翻倍我選三檔你們都聽過連發科
我選這些股票是普通會員也有發喔
那你沒得獎我還沒把財政科算進去喔
是
你們自己看
他說
不要覺得我股票無聊
我真的是每天講一樣的事情
因為我是
聯發科你自己看
你看聯發科今天展有什麼用
4000塊以上
我平均出在4000塊以上
是
問你一件事
我在這邊買啦
我有沒有講說聯發科最厲害的事
我有沒有講說
聯發科在1000多元的時候
我說把台積電換成聯發科
有沒有假
有
你們不理我
把台積電換聯發科喔
然後我很準喔
就像環球經營一樣
一樣都是1000塊的
我說把國具
你換成環球金
有沒有講
有
我都講了很強欸
我不是嘴一檔而已欸
環球金這一段
有沒有
說說
聯發科這一段
這賺到是三倍
我只算100%多而已
三倍有沒有看到
1430元到快4900
對不對
不是賺到三倍嗎
是
算三倍以上啊
考試沒有
我到1000多元買了
聯發科就算了
國具
是不是
就是300多元買
應該300多元買
到這邊有沒有呢
國具300多到600多走掉走太快了然後怎麼樣換環球金有沒有沒有比較這又一倍囉環球金有沒有環球金有500多塊買的喔
我記得五六百塊買的喔
500多塊你看
而且每次拉回都是25%
有沒有看到
500多塊到1000多
是兩倍啊
快兩倍啊
我都算一倍就好了
一倍一倍一倍
三個一倍不是三倍
是八倍啊各位
200萬變1600萬
我們今年很多會員真的賺的不止幾千萬
我這樣講你自己看啊
有哪個會員說我今年績效很差你告訴我
你不在那我不能說每一檔股票都一定都很強啊
就我前一次只能講說每一檔股票都賺錢
沒錯那事實啦每一檔進出
現在沒有啊可是我10檔真的也有中7 8檔
而且那一中是賺很多耶
我敢這樣講我問你們拜託拜託留言打點我
是不是跟著折挫發大財
借投資產竟然賺450萬人
你在我會員裡面算小咖啊
這預測率真的很準
有沒有 這都是粉絲啊
我讓你及時留言啊
投資產很帥一點都不老
因為我花很多時間
叫什麼
健康啊 對不對 我會請莉莉說
記得提醒我要量一下血壓
我要自己量一下血壓 是不是 我跟你講
每天吃很多保健食品啊 莉莉都看到
我不吃那麼多保健食品 我不重訓
我不深蹲 我不這樣重訓 我跟你講的是
怎麼保護大家
等到你說我意志力很好
是不是
感謝者讓我賺錢
每天看者者都雞皮掉掉兩地
這樣行情很難差耶
其實很多投過分析師績效很差
我是不要丟人家
我真的績效好到爆
我真的是運氣
運氣加實力啦 真的
好不好
OK嗎 如果加會員
我們今天等一下有推專案
我跟你說真的 你要不要加隨便你喔
因為我很忙喔
來
今年三個月五百萬
又是會員見證有沒有看到
會員認證快賺一千萬
有沒有看到 會員講的喔
是
沒人講的喔
因為我選的股票都是低基期啦
是不是
會員認證快賺1000萬喔
三個月五百萬喔
你看有沒有會員更多的
從敲桌子的力道就知道
只值還能做20年
沒有錯
只是配色系統好看
謝謝大家有沒有看到
來我問你喔
我就問你
我就問哪個會員嘛
你告訴我嘛
是不是
你來
大部分絕道的會員都是很滿意的
什麼賺1000萬賺500萬有沒有
有沒有
這跟大家講你看
不相信你們都噴出去了
所以有些人吐槽我就說
你可以不要吐槽我
你就直接跟我對坐嘛
今天行情
這個你看一次
只有最差的是環球晶
可是環球晶長不停
為什麼環球晶
環球晶跌中美晶跟它拉
為什麼環球晶跌下去
我告訴你
中時務一定有看我們的節目啊
我說過環球晶在展上去
環球晶的展上去要被什麼樣
處置了
你不要開玩笑
那被處置變20分鐘
是
正下我規定要我們透明
如果今天再上去的話
禮拜五
禮拜四再上去的話
禮拜五就要除置了
所以今天跌剛好
我給他100分
我巴不得他跌
我有沒有講過
我說希望他不要漲太快
有
我要隨時要被除置有沒有講
所以他為什麼中施物現在拉
拉中美金
因為中美金前陣子沒漲啊
中美金哪有漲
你不要說這有漲喔
我跟你講你看月星就知道
中美金以前有多少錢過
中美金以前有375元
不要不要不要那是2007
那時候太陽能的題材
所以不要管這個題材
你看只會信手你都記憶
都在我的頭髮裡面記憶
2007年那時候綠燃最夯
我什麼事都記得
一來我記憶性真好
尤其是有關股票的記憶性
二來我就是活字典
我在投資市場30年
年紀就做股票
20年我年紀就考上分析師了
20年的分析師記錄
每一個都在我腦海裡
所以我記憶效於人家很正常
加到現在我每天還在工作
你真的可以再問一次
這個問莉莉
我是不是很說凌晨然後五六點
因為奇怪 只會沒在休息
你懂不懂
是
而且我不是說某個時間而已喔
我不是說
比如說晚上九點到十二點
是我加班時間
不是
我是有什麼重要的消息
我就在Tim子留言說
我明天要講這一段
來 中美金以前250
你看前陣子比較200
2024年有沒有看到
看周姓就好
他有多少錢
250元過有沒有看到
有
最近才噴出去啊
是最近啊
以前有250元過啊
234元
有
現在再噴出去啊
看日線來講沒有漲很多
所以我中時我當然拉中美金啊
所以我買中美金
我覺得真的對大家很好啊
我還懶得算台生科呢
是不是
而且就有價有量而言
是中美金比較厲害你知道嗎
台生科在79億有沒有
中美金呢
動不動快200億
我要選有價有量的股票
我不知道為什麼
說實話啦 我覺得今年運氣比較好
我說實話 我自己在想啊
我不知道是不是老天皇我成員得雪啦
我在財里面有應該以前有中石戶啊
他們可能覺得我真的很老實
不是我在講的
我在講一件事喔
我是全台灣唯一法院證交所證明
絕不跟主力掛鉤的分析師
因為去年有人亂搞
同業有人亂搞
有人亂搞
看我營收很好
看我是全台灣最紅的分寄師
這邊給我攻擊我
還去慫恿什麼自救會
然後告我
告我以後對不對
是
你知道嗎
通常要被判刑是起訴
一審二審定業嘛
對
所以被起訴還算有可能是清白的
不是
我不是被起訴
我也不是不起訴
不起訴是說
你沒有什麼罪證
我是怎麼樣
更輕微的
法官覺得你們無理取道
警察官覺得你無理請到
上面的檢察官認同
郭總是清白的
確骨114年他自1233號
直接簽結
簽結兩個字
你去問所有法律人
為什麼簽結
他們行文去證交所也查過啦
你懂嗎
是
真七大隊有去查過啦
有去問證交所
我每一檔股票這些
我有沒有跟
主力配合
有沒有就是我買股票叫我會買股票
有沒有投出貨
有沒有什麼特別點也會出貨
沒有啊 本來就沒有
我不屑賺這種錢啊
你叫我要賺這種錢
我過頭不死一死算了
我真的不屑
我慌我清白 我會很開心啊
我跟你講
在社會上很多人
嘴巴說不愛錢 很愛錢
我說我很開心
我就把他們折磨
去年的時候我很生氣
當中很開心
成員德學
千節兩個字
我學到了法律
因為學到什麼叫千節
有
學到了
你以前有學過嗎
以前沒學過對不對
沒有
我以前沒學過啊
所以證交所直接證明
我每一個會員的進出
不會有人故意到
我叫會員買然後就出不掉
我說出什麼出
200億你要自己賣就自己賣
不用跟我配合啦
對不對
是
我說沒錯吧
沒錯
我要買一堆股票
200億的成交料有什麼
找我的
不用
所以可能很多通知
大悟看我的股票
真的清清白白
現在也願意拉啦
是不是
大家做大家的就好了
我絕對不會出賣我的會員
而且怎麼出賣啊
選那麼大股票
這跟大家講
檢察官會不會照顧看影片
我不知道
我跟你講 檢察官也是看證據
不會說我是不是粉絲
我跟你講很多人嘴巴說怎麼樣怎麼樣
做的都是怎麼樣
我跟你講 檢察官也圈粉
謝謝他啦 我都愛你們啦
人時不時在到最後都看得出來啦
好不好 我就說不要比績笑
我是全台灣分析師裡面捐最多錢的
這幾年來我已經捐一兩千萬了
檯面上 我還要捐更多
我希望我這輩子
雖然我錢沒到非常多
但我希望我能捐 20
官司救護車我能捐22台
能捐超過1億元
我現在目前已經晚一年一輛救護車
一輛救護車快五百萬喔
準備了
年底要交第二台車
OK嗎
哲哲明天會不會繼續大噴
明天有機會
來
等一下再跟你講我的股票
我們要去收你的會不會緣
來
你要不要參加隨便你
我現在有翻倍199
我在講這
我有關三檔股票
我還少賺很多檔喔
我看你少賺什麼檔
我不知道我只賺
我還少賺南亞科啊
南亞科賺好幾倍
是
南亞科我從50元一直做啊
翻倍199專案
翻倍199的專案
你要不要隨便
我三檔股票一倍就1000萬變8000萬了
你說1000萬變8000萬怎麼可能
那就100萬變800萬
怎麼不可能
很多會員的喔
真的好多會員真的賺幾千萬
剛才一堆的人講的啊
翻倍199的專案有沒有看到
來
來來
而且最誇張的是
我股票最誇張的是
我能報耶你知道嗎
很多分析是不敢報
我很敢報
所以你們有時候會員有時候會員
問我說
你賠個5% 10%你怎麼不走
莫名其妙
我是要賺100%的
5%18%你受不了了
你不要再找我
好不好
受不了了
拜託你買台灣50就好了
真的啦
台灣50機器也不錯了
來
這跟大家講
來世界噴了嗎
沒看到沒
對啊
檢察官搞不好
法官檢察官搞不好
我指著會言
我不敢這樣說啦
因為他們不會讓我知道
不用啦
法官檢察官
你們就買台灣50
犯者
很多人警察也是認識我
會不會回黨
回黨不重要
我再給你一次
你們有生之年
可以看到台灣股市十萬點
那我你回答是要加碼還是要賣掉
你賣掉你可能買不回來喔
是
加碼
你們有錢就加碼
記得你們以後會愛我
你想分散風險
怕台灣真的萬一統一
我說萬一啦
我講萬一
我這個沒什麼政治意行
那就買0062
買納斯達克ETF
就這樣子好不好
分散風險
這樣就夠了
基本上這樣夠
這樣你已經贏了99%
百分之不要90
百分之98
99人沒錯
百分之99人啦
百分之95的賞戶了
沒有沒有
自己贏了95%的人了
好不好
你站住贏了95%的人
投資產太神了
有誠信用捐救護車
謝謝大家
好不好
謝謝投資產
中美金賺50萬還沒下車
謝謝大家
自己選的股票套實實的
這會員是不是
跟投資產三次都賺40%以上
40%真的太少了
每天看直播看得很爽
謝謝大家
賺越多捐越多
這則美國通貨是不是大好
沒有錯啊
來我昨天是不是講
我先講中美金
我們先來
我喝個水
我先讓你秀一下我們的簡訊
好不好
好
你看聯發科我們那時候是賺那個
現在是大概3000多塊嘛
我們在4270元的時候
第一次賣出有沒有知道
對
賣一半嘛
這沒錯吧
精彩今天直接跳通鎖子展停
一個人展停沒有沒有
精彩我們從200元開始做有沒有知道
226元對不對
是
然後今天每天直接
我精彩有沒有跟大家講過
來看一下
我精彩
等一下給大家看重播啦
我精彩那時候我們就想說
我說中時務不拉展停
我是看不起他
我開玩笑對不對
我不是要激怒他
我不是要讓他激怒你以為
來 我精彩你自己看一下
我今天做到106%了
你先唸一下簡訊 我喝過水 來
7月15號
從哪算3 激動一點 開始
7月15號 星期三
恭喜3374
精彩開盤不到
一分鐘就強勢
鎖上漲停 再創歷史新高
我們買進到現在
最高已經大賺106%
財富翻倍
我持續看好它
手上持股獲利續報
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
恭喜大家
最高已經賺106%了
我剛才是算
對 我剛才是算三檔股票而已
你們都可以作證喔
聯發課我們賺一倍
不要說沒做
國際普通委員也快一倍了
關於普通委員
還有什麼
那個
環球金
環球金 環球金賺快三倍了
現在賺快三倍
一倍就是一百萬變三百萬
這三檔就會一百萬變八百萬
我還沒有算精彩耶
金彩座的股票之前我套很久欸
我今天跟他說不一樣的
你們不相信
金彩就是幾部低基期的股票啊
我就說你們為什麼
你知道為什麼現在很多人績效不好嗎
因為台灣股市明明就四萬多點
你們買一些七八萬點的股票搞什麼
是
除非基本面很像記憶體現在南亞科那麼好啊
我叫你買兩萬點的股票
你不理我
我所有股票金彩一開始買的時候都兩萬點的股票
那以前的什麼2萬點的股票
他以前200多塊啊
他以前300塊200塊
中美金也是一樣
以前200多塊現在100多塊
那不是2萬點的股票
那時候他中美金200多塊的時候
股市2萬多點啊
那我為什麼不買100多塊的中美金
這件事
中美金在以前200多塊的時候
股市2萬多點
現在100多元股市快5萬點了
為什麼不買中美金
黃金金也是一樣啊
以前快1000元啊
2萬多點啊
我都是買這種低級級
我就是很邏輯很簡單啊
我要低級股票都拉完了你買台達電就十倍了你笑死了買那個幹嘛你買那個聯發科他笑死人喊一萬塊他們有本事就在一千多塊說喊聯發科一萬塊
我禁他這條漢子啦
沒本事不要這樣喊
有些外資
當然外資壓力很大
就像我講一講
我這個00981A
你最近看績效比較不好
我也不是要丟他
你會覺得現在要下來的
我反而不想丟人家
你懂不懂
這沒什麼
00981A我覺得
我覺得算是很強
我跟你講其實
我覺得啦 外資有些亂搞
但我覺得怎麼樣
我覺得如果是主動型ETF的基金技能
我比較佩服一點 你知道什麼嗎
為什麼
他們壓力很大 每天拼生死啊
不像外資啊 出傷嘴啊
你有時候有些外資你都不知道是出貨的
你知道
可是這些經紀人是憑真材實料的
績效一不好 內部都要開檢討會
你知道 天天要開你知道嗎
拉遠一點點 你看最近主動增長能強嗎
不強啦 是不是
最強的主動統一
就是00981A都不強了
你看一下是不是0050很好
感覺0050比他好
有沒有底底高看的是不是
對
你自己看就好
底部你自己看啊
所以我說你們什麼都不知道
就買台灣50就好
有沒有是不是有點越墊越高
是
畫條線就知道了啊
唉唷連這個
可是我再講下去
我變得罪人家
因為這些經紀人都會看我的節目
我只跟你講喔
他們是條漢子好不好
你看他這樣子
都快跌破頸線你知道嗎
你懂嗎
當然我覺得不會
我覺得台灣股市會上去的 好不好
我只要告訴你很多我都預測成功的
你們久了
很多會有沒有跟著我
粉絲會跟著我
因為久了他會知道
哲哲不是要賺錢的
哲哲不是最主要不是要賺錢
是你要賺錢
我先跟你做朋友
我們再來談生意
我先跟你做朋友我們再談生意
朋友做到了
生意有沒有談成功
我覺得還好
為什麼
就我昨天很生氣的一點
是我跟你講的
今天你不要覺得我說我很帥
我體格很好
我看起來很年輕
那不重要
因為當我股票賠錢的時候
我居然是金城武文
你也不理我
就算我長得很Ugly
我長得很醜
投資廟
今天我股票飆暫停在暫停
你也有看完節目
我跟一般網紅不一樣
我們是分析師不是網紅
好不好
來來
來看一下
前幾個月玩單充產輸了
加入會員到現在
一個月已經賺完會費了
我活動懷疑者則是參與時光過來的
你們看啊
這是剛才秀的是什麼
精彩嘛 沒錯嘛 對不對
對
你看不到一分鐘就暫停對不對
你看一下喔
精彩從什麼時候開始漲
我們看一下重播
走的時候臭屁一下
而且今天大家還是要提醒我
要講一下CPI
通膨跟台積電法說
不要一直臭屁
我們還是要有專業性
不會
其實我裡面還是有些專業性啊
比如說我是低基期
有些人不知道
每次說我在重複
邏輯很差
我問你件事啊
股票天天暫停 我要不要講
要啦
你知道什麼我一直重複嗎
我股票就天天漫 我讓大家重複講啊
我股票有時候跌的時候 我還是得講啊
不講你又說我逃避
來來喔
激怒大戶有沒有看到激怒你圍有沒有看到
有沒有看到
這個時候你看喔
這是
7月8日嘛對不對 7月8日嘛對不對
對
上禮拜這個時間喔
來看看我們怎麼激怒大戶 怎麼激怒你圍
告訴他說你今天拉暫停
你明天給我拉暫停
哈哈哈哈
那開玩笑刺激他一下
這大戶嗚
真的啦 我覺得那個大戶
如果今天硬拉的這大戶喔
明天沒有拉起展庭
我看不起他
看不起他 我說哪個
哪個拉展庭 她就講的是精彩
你這邊這麼有Gas敢拉展庭
明天就應該再拉了啦
聽懂嗎
這種走勢是明天應該再拉展庭
但我不敢說百分之百
這時候在哪邊
今天在320元
等一下給你嘗一下
就是我剛才說
這個今天是15號嘛對不對
8號的時候
好
來啦
好不好
我也常被他洗來洗去
這個金彩被他洗來洗去
我就覺得你今天這種拉法
你明天就應該拉展停了啦
至少怎麼樣都要半更啦
明天沒有5%
我覺得不及格
這知道
這是我要跟大家講的
你看我都預告要拉展停有沒有到
是
324嘛對不對
對
你看看金彩現在多少錢了
上禮拜
你今天我已經買很多賺很多了
400元的有沒有到
扯不扯再看一下喔
有沒有到嗎
這開個主動型ETF
應該績銷最強吧
對不對
可是我還是在講一次
我不是要將別人主動型ETF
我覺得主動型ETF壓力很大
外資壓力也很大
OK嗎
我不是要跟你們說的
只是我覺得壓力大是大一回事
我覺得不能亂講東西
不能亂喊話
比如說那一萬元的那個
的聯發科我覺得有點過分
過分是我覺得或許會到
但邏輯不對
好不好
你不能喊後年的EPS
好
我們看講到哪邊
7號嘛
來
8號
有沒有 像之前大摩講外資講機體不行的
那現在是不是要改口了
每次變來變去 你都不知道到底他做做還做空
好累 外資讓我這種寒法啊
你看7月8號我是說明天要拉展停有沒有
所以一根展停 兩根展停有沒有
過一個禮拜你看 是不是7月8號
對不對 對
320元在這邊喔
我說你明天沒拉展停還丟臉
果然明天要拉展停了
開高給你走低 今天給你展一根
你有沒有預設成功後 然後結果四天內
7月8號
對對差不多
四天內
我們看一下
為什麼少一根
對因為沒有颱風架
颱風架
你看我都做得很仔細
我說7月8號到現在不是一個禮拜
應該五根K線嗎
因為才四個交易人
你看看真的不要放颱風架了
不是你不要說我
不要說什麼我是灌老闆
那個不是我什麼我灌老闆
是我們都灌會員
就冠會員啦
會員希望我多上班啦好不好
哪個會員不希望我颱風天上班
而且禮拜五重點是
禮拜五沒有什麼風雨
你家有風有雨
那不會到要下
不會到那個時德
應該犯颱風架
規定就規定好不好
扯遠了我再講下去好像變鬥爭別人
好不好沒有
扯遠了
可是你看我連颱風架我都
颱風架沒有預測成功
但颱風的趨勢我預測成功
來
拉起來有沒有看到
拉起來
四天裡面兩個展停板
我那時候說大戶喔
不拉展停我瞧不起他
開玩笑的
不然Pill稍微激怒一下
當然是開玩笑的
沒有要特地激怒人家
你看精彩的這樣子
很誇張
好啦
我們解一下盤牢
解一下其他的股票
盤氏大盤
等在講環球金啊
在講那些
還沒講環球金
對股票創新高
中美金也是嘛對不對
我們先講一下
來
SK海利市是要議價對不對
對不對 37%
昨天議價50%
是
所以美國根本沒有存在記憶體泡沫
記憶體泡沫是亞洲人士在爬 你知道嗎
美國昨天好像長
SK海力士要長20-30%
還算率值升高 ADR
好不好
ADR好不好
議價幅度差很多人們的
OK嗎
這是原始價格
你不懂沒關係
就是什麼叫議價
海力士跟台積電都一樣
在本土的證交所有掛牌上市
有個價格
是
在國外要籌資嘛 募資也有個價格
匯率換算以後
國外的價格
台積電多10%
懂不懂 就像麥當勞一樣
台灣賣100元
美國賣120元
怪怪的吧
重點它是股票啊
台積電賣1000元
假設台積電賣1000元
假設台積電賣2000元
人家外面賣2200元
美國賣2200元
那懂不懂
海力是比較誇張
怎麼樣 20% 100% 100000
賣200萬人家可能要賣到300萬去了
聽懂的意思嗎
因為意價50%
今天才收斂
假設50%是這樣子的意思
OK嗎?
understand
欸
200萬你賣人家300萬
我問索
所以代表美國是願意追價的
所以基金不會泡沫
第二個通膜
我昨天講的東西有沒有講
華許說
令人高通膜
華許正在講
所以華許是蠻硬的喔
滑雪很硬喔
有沒有 滑雪很硬喔
Fed主席滑雪很硬喔
幸好昨天怎麼樣
所以真正
我跟你講一件事
至少美國股市現在不會崩盤
你知道為什麼不會崩盤嗎
因為最怕的是資金行情被抽回
我再講一次
最怕的是資金行情被抽回
Fed主席非常的硬派
我昨天是說過一件事情
來 我做一個圖來一件事
來
我說Fed的利益多少
3.75 有沒有講
這是CPI 通膨
我說你通膨不能高於3.75太多
是
我用4%來做一個標準好了
多一點點
那也有一點空間嗎
我說你現在再多4%就不行了
結果幸好
本來就預估怎麼樣
這件事
費的利率大概3.5到3.75
就是基準利率
是
你把它當作存款利率就好了好不好
假設啦
假設我只把錢畫而已
你的一個存款利率
一個費的利率3.75
你不能通膨4%啊
你通膨4%變怎麼樣
變負利率了
是
我100万我看起来好像存到103万
103万7500元假设
结果我通膨是4%
实际上我钱是变少的
我是负利率的
所以我昨天很多人说喜欢我这一段
为什么
你只要记得通膨不可以高利率太多
通膨高利率太多那怎么样
他就会把利率调起来
重点是通膨这么高利率比较低
那就把利率调高
要嘛就把通膨降下去
要嘛把利率调高
中長期利率就是要比通膨高一點
這樣不懂
懂
那我問你啊
本來4.2
4.2利率有沒有比通膨高
沒有
這樣不行喔
那我就要升息了
幸好我預估值最新通膨是3.8
那差不多對不對
對
算了
預估3.8
實際3.5更低
那更不會怎麼樣
升息啦
我是說利率比通膨高
很好啊
4.2的通膨比利率高
危險
利率比較低
可是3.5的通膨
比利率低
这时候我不断再升级
我已经把它压下来了
我记起来有一句话
我教你口诀
利率要把通盟压下来
一起练
好
现在利率有没有把通盟压下来
有啊
因为利率3.75比通盟高
知道没
就这个逻辑
所以这是一个实质大利多
好不好
有时候就比较20年的信手年来
真的
其实我现在
也没有花很多时间
就講這些話說不話說
就有些人講這句話對不對
有些人我是天生很會講話
你問理理我沒什麼時間準備
可是我準備是一整天在準備資料
可是我不會節目上
我要告訴你我要講什麼特別什麼梗
你懂嗎 你可以作證
因為我每天很忙
可是你看你就會記得我這些教學
就是特別天生適合教學
來大摩推演法說
我之前看過大摩的法說
推演我說爛
他說那時候會長什麼10% 20%
我說很扯
因為已經長完了
來
大摩的很多的分析師
不論大摩或外資分析
他們最大問題是
他們可以預測基本面
但不會預測股市
不一樣喔
你懂不懂
什麼叫預測基本面
不是要股市
來
2021年
2022年那個
航運股從20元
10元不到漲到200元
從200元跌到20元
對不對
從200元跌到100元以下
腰斬嘛對不對
那個時候
基本面很好
但股市不好
但股價不好
所以他們會預測基本面
可是有時候股價真的走勢跟他們預測不一樣
可是我講BUT
這次我認同他講的情境
基本上跟我的預測差不多
我說重點就是營收
營收好不好看一下
營收2026年營收有沒有看到
怎麼樣大摩說這個
就是台積電法說大摩情境分析嘛對不對
營收有沒有增加40%以上
他說這要基本情境
近40%的情境我認同
我認同
只要超過40%
我有說過有可能超過40%
我比他們更樂觀
他說基本情境只有10%
我認同
我認為最差就是差不多
約接近40%
他會跟我說
營收成超過30%
變怎麼樣
變成我說是高位數嘛
中高位數
就是35到40嘛
對
我覺得他有可能這樣講
甚至於超過 above
超過40%
我覺得超過40%
機率不只只有20%
而且他說
山上都會講啊
說哇 熱關情境
之前好像只能漲5%以上
我覺得之前太誇張
這一次有可能 為什麼這次有可能
來喔 為什麼這樣所以我跟你講說我跟外資的差別是我重點是我糾正別人我是告訴你為什麼這一次台積電法說有沒有壓寶行情有沒有上場行情有沒有漲嘛沒有漲啊
它其實在一個大區間整領平台
沒錯吧對不對
是
再看一下喔
基本上它就在一個大區間整領平台
就這麼大 沒錯吧
對
它沒有怎麼動
所以它有本錢樂觀的情況之下
有機會發動
這就是我說的
為什麼我說五月
七月要五萬點不是不可能
開台地獻法說
所以七月就是上半月很無聊
下半月很精彩
台地獻法說會不會
台地獻法會不會漲價啊
台地獻法會漲價啊
人家都漲個一倍
我漲個5% 10%還要吧
為什麼不能漲價
我有價值啊
你SK海利是
記憶體很缺
你還有SK海利是
你還有什麼
還有美光
對不對
還有三星
你看三家獨大咧
還沒有含中國的產商
是不是什麼藏心存儲
什麼的 相關的
所以我要告大家 藏心藏江
存儲
我要告訴大家什麼
台積電不一樣
台積電就是一家獨大
尤其仙境之城就是一家獨大
它單能有斬價的一個空間
那斬完價以後 不好意思
是講難聽的
這營收
就是台積電要不要做出來而已
OK嗎 台積電要不要做出來
你聽懂嗎
是
所以我覺得是有機會
我覺得就是他講的
我覺得最差數價就35
也不會35%
會最差是35到45
然後跟你講說中高位數
或告訴你接近40
或者是40以上
我覺得40以上的機率有一定有
所以理論上台積電應該
接下來會漲2%
你明天可以壓保
我覺得明天台股股股
應該會有很多人壓保
這樣幾分呢
40喔
來
所以我已經告訴你兩個
一個CPI是好事
所以CPI是很大力多
那CPI總經驗是很大力多
至少資金不會收回
因為你不會升息
升息就要把資金收回
對於股市不利基求這句話
好 第二個 台積電法說又很好
記憶體又絕對大反攻
台灣股市應該是雅谷有機會最強
所以該壓寶 壓寶 OK嗎
那我壓寶什麼 台積電法說好
台積電如果資本支出也會增加
精彩不是要拉展鈴
夭壽
6189 6187 萬論
1000多塊
你知道以前我買不到100塊
我還被人家罵你知道嗎
真的喔
買了又跌啊
莫名其妙就欣欣這樣
也有什麼
跟很多股票就是要犯產的
這萬多個1000塊 你給我說精彩
雖然不是這樣比較
但是很多台積電資本資助幹電股都漲十倍
真的很誇張
來 我們來看一下樊軒
樊軒代表多少 6196
樊軒看起來叫彭主影 你看不出來嗎
樊軒現行就看起來彭主影
跟什麼2377 維新也是一樣
我都不懂了 昨天有人說
你維新不講了 這些維新很大
你看不出來維新的現行很漂亮嗎
微信線型很漂亮
你還抱怨微信的人喔
真的我認為你不是我會員
我會員不會這樣抱怨我啊
因為基本上我其他股票亂賺半天了
你們看不出來微信就是要噴著線型
那我覺得你很遜
我是說真的
你看不出來微信要噴出去的
然後你還抱怨我
你真的很遜
你絕對不適合做股票
微信的線型很漂亮
如果你今天跟我爭論說
投資長
資源怎麼看
資源我還不敢跟你講打包票
所以這線型很漂亮
我跟你講 2377 維新
線型看起來你就會十個有九個懂技術線型
他會說這線型很漂亮就是要噴啊
他就是要噴啊
大多大行情他就是要噴啊
是
他就是要噴出去
他就是要噴出去的
你不要懷疑他就是要噴出去的
他明天就有機會噴出去的
那維新符合什麼
你自己看維新錢多少錢
拜託以前216元
台灣股市兩三萬點的時候他216元
現在台灣股市四五萬點
他還不到200元
啊不要是低級
又符合我的環球金中美金
又符合我的聯發科
1430元的聯發科
又符合我300元的國具
所以我告訴你
現在已經越來越少了
你再不參加會員
你真的會後悔
所以我今天推出
翻倍19的專案
我告訴你
就類似我
就這樣
我自己說買大送小嘛
是
買環球金送中美金
買高價股送低價股
我就是一個組合
一個combo
組合拳
一個密
一個整個一個組合一個mix
整個把它組合起來
應該說一個set
不管你的啦
我不是要跟你繞英文啦
一個組合我要讓你翻倍再翻倍再翻倍
三個股票都再翻一倍
1000萬是變8000萬
你就1000元
100萬變800萬已經快變1000萬
100萬變800萬
翻倍199專案
我要找像維新這種股票
像中美新這種股票
都是在低基期股票
在人家就是低基期股票
你自己看低基期股票
你不覺得很變態他嗎
是不是
不覺得很變態嗎 這走勢
是
是不是
你看微信一樣
這種低基期股票
然後
中美金這種低基期股票
只能噴出去的天展停
天展停
他是不是連三天展停
沒有沒有 昨天9%而已
所以真的很誇張
那看一下我們的績效
精彩 直接跳過展停鎖死喔
今天直接跳過手 妳鎖死喔
看完不到一分鐘喔
我愛美元不是我中愛美金嗎
美金啊 美金不是美元嗎
是
是不是
中美金 180 190
那時候有人抱怨說
我只能中美金再跟我炫耀我沒有買到
婚姻不是有留言嗎
是
馬上讓你買個夠
190買不到
160買不到
沒關係 207買得到吧
213買得到吧
現在 230元不是no no no
弄弄弄弄
現在快300元了
我看對不對
恭喜5483中美金
股價連兩天
恭喜我愛美元5483中美金
股價連兩天90度其他
沒有錯吧
昨天這樣拉了 很扯吧
所以我好愛回黨
你看 喔 這樣拉耶
中時務現在都喜歡拉我股票
因為他知道
我不會出貨給你
我也不會配合別人出貨給賞戶
我最不屑這種事
證交所證明
我們還去行文證交所查
查每一筆就進出啦
查不到任何異狀
所以千結
連不起訴都沒有
比不起訴更輕微
中時乎大物愛死我的股票了
我愛美元58% 美金
股價零兩天90度其拉
直噴暫停等等
我們颱風價錢
還零兩天再次加碼
讓你不只愛美元還賺上台幣
我買進到現在
最高已經獲利58%
上禮拜不是還賺10幾%嗎
是
手上的事故或利序報
要翻倍了
我剛才只是講
我只舉例喔
國具
我只是去那個聯發科
聯發科有賺一倍了吧
國具有吧
然後那個
環球金有吧
不只一倍吧
不只
我都賺100%而已喔
100萬然後人又轉轉轉
100萬變800萬
我還沒有算中美金欸
我還沒有算精彩欸
精彩也算
我還沒有算欸
還有南亞科欸
還有南亞科
講不完
娜哥啊
好玩酒精
黃昀青
跌停的時候我還敢買
哎呀 講不完
那會員都可以見
剛剛看到沒有會員
那吐槽我嘛 對不對
來
黃昀青賺1900了
那1900的話
那不對喔
那是100萬變成
變多少
1000多萬
你自己算嘛
這哪一幣1000多萬啊
天啊
我在乘1.9
乘1.4倍
乘1.9
我439
變大概1200萬
天啊
真的變1200萬
真的很誇張
如果沒算錯的話
2.29
沒錯沒錯
2.29沒錯
至少有1000多萬
快1000萬快1000萬快1000萬
如果是2.29的話
一倍乘上兩倍變4的嘛
4乘上2點
2.9啦
2.9沒錯
那快3倍啦
那就是快變1200萬
沒錯沒錯沒錯
這也是喔
如果我環球晶是最後一個嘛對不對
換的話對不對
不過我這是用500多元的環境去算啦
沒關係啦
我只告訴你賺1倍
再賺1倍
再賺1.9倍
是1000萬
是100萬賺到1100多萬
賺10倍喔
我沒有說完
那你懂嗎
很誇張對不對
很誇張
我就問你
會員朋友們哪一句話在唬你
我再問你這件事
我這些股票有沒有賺那麼多
我還只嗅普通會員簡訊
我不要
我就8倍就好了啦
我只要跟你講
我最近可以
通常我有時候卡這邊啦
我這場不一定有的話
那沒有關係 我不管嘛
我只要問你這件事
我這些股票最低標準
我有沒有賺一倍嘛
有
你硬要吹毛求疵之後
國際簡訊會員差一點點
可是很多不是簡訊會員賺更多啊
你聽懂嗎
是
我連環球金190不是
就算給你看啊
如果你都有一倍一倍這樣賺的話
是1000萬賺到
100萬賺到快1000萬
1000萬賺到1億多
還沒有含南亞科耶
還沒有含金財耶
不要算了啦 我真的少賺
給你少賺很多欸
納克幾個 你們看
納克也賺105%
跟精彩一樣啦
我跟你講 我這個節目真的很無聊
每天在數賺錢
可是你們都知道
我的股票有沒有有價有量
有
我是不是講很久
是
我是不是暗示你
我是不是中美金
我都暗示你 我愛美金
我說這題送分題啦
一對人猜我愛美金啦
我愛中美金啦
我愛美金猜出來中美金啦
台股No.1
台灣No.1猜台聖哥
你買幾張
買一張
哼哼哼哼
難怪跟我會員錢差那麼多
唉 阿凡宣65%
講不完
所以你們不要說
我怎麼沒有去講紅海或什麼的
我也是會跟你講一件股票
紅海這邊真的也不該跌
只是他就慢嘛
能怎麼辦
是不是
講不完
唉 接下來5347
世界先進看起來要噴囉
世界先進要噴出去
其實很誇張
世界先進也是低基期
唉 群年我覺得這可惜
群年老闆一直在上電視
好 股票就拉不起來
可是有機會噴出去好不好
我覺得最愛噴的
下一檔不是世界
我有看到 我先預告囉
微星
沒有 帆軒 帆軒
帆軒可能明天又噴出去了
精彩跟帆軒
是
精彩 帆軒
我已經有順序了喔
然後微星
世界先進再下一批
我先告訴你順序了
很恐怖對不對
現在幾分了
我只要結束了
來啦 我愛你們啦
所有會員可以見證啦
好不好
你去想看你要長相分心師啦
就是這麼多股票漲停 漲不停啦
所以我要告訴大家
今天啦
來來 等一下
今天版要唱歌對不對 來不及了
來有沒有看到
有沒有看到
這跟大家講 來來來
黃金缺我缺我
折成的美男股票有價有量有沒有看到
這太厲害了有沒有看到
沒聲音 怎麼說沒聲音的
為什麼說沒聲音
以後你們沒有聲音對不對
直接按重新整理好不好
那個怎麼沒有跟我講啦
歪歪
以後只要沒有聲音
就直接重新整理好不好
OK嗎
OK嗎 好不好
又沒聲音了 怪怪的
重新進入就可以了 好不好
太誇張的跡象
剛才聲音跟畫面有點延遲
以後重新整理
整理要拉遠一點點
就按這邊
網址按個Enter 好不好
扯遠了啦 你看我
幹嘛每天看我節目
看簡訊比較實在
看節目來不及買股票
方貝190專案啦
再一堆股票
什麼南亞科賺一倍
什麼金財賺一倍
什麼國巨賺一倍
我累死我
什麼什麼
什麼環球星賺1.0
賺190%
我懶得賺了
還有什麼股票
真的精彩
中美金啦 也是今年大展特展啦
太強了
去想看你要展明
單分一十單的20年來
最強的就是今年
最厲害的就是現在啦
一堆股票
翻倍19的專案
歡迎來一下請
0806-80085
或叫我賴斯汀我
不論對我或錯
我一切一切的報告在前面
翻倍19的專案
我要你翻倍
努力翻倍
再翻倍
讓你賺更多
益助各位能夠賺更多
趕快來參加會員喔
掰掰
本公司与所推介分析之个别有价证券
无不当之财务利益关系
本节目资料仅供参考
投资人应独立判断
审慎评估并自负投资风险
谢谢大家